ladies and gentlemen I bring to you now
black bush after careful examination of
me and my cabinet agree that that area
is definitely right for regime change
all right but if I can be real about it
be real sign real real real shot kill my
father man he played it say where'd he
try to kill your father
meanwhile President Bush and British
Prime Minister Tony Blair offered a
spirited explanation for a possible war
with Iraq this nigga very possibly has
weapons of mass destruction I can't
sleep on it not on my watch that's not
how I wrote it this serious now if you
want to take my word for launching X
Tony Blair he got a hold of seven
telogen watch what's up Tony we don't
know much random niggas with things like
that is George so eloquently put it down
I'm with him a hundred percent of the
way we go know what he hurts if the
United States goes to war with Iraq will
it first have to provide evidence that
Saddam Hussein has weapons of mass
destruction so far the UN has found
nothing but President Bush counters with
this gladdy to tell you what the you can
do with an aluminum - they don't skate
bad I didn't wanna say this
the mom bought some yellow cake okay in
Africa he went to Africa and he bought
yellow cake are you sure yes I'm sure a
bitch ridiculous
me jib just coming back from Africa
cradle up are you sure it was yellow
cake
y'all niggas don't believe me I got
yellow cake right here don't drop that
yeah pray to God you don't drop it
yellow cake right a sensitive accusation
for this administration is the theory
held by many that the real reason the
u.s. is so interested in toppling Sodom
is control of the oil that Iraq is
sitting on what about people who say
you're only interested in the Middle
East for oil what huh Oh Oh bitch you
cook
President Bush met with UN Secretary
General Kofi Annan and made it clear the
US will act even if the UN is reluctant
you when you have problem with that you
know what you should do you should
sanction me sanction me with your army
[Applause]
but you won't need them when you in task
we're selling fake hats
I love Gucci when I see it then got rich
I got a Coalition of the Willing I got
40 nations ready to roll son
like who say that like who angling
Japan's sending Playstations Thank You
O'Neal said they're willing to drop
bombs of the bed bed Zulu nation not
doing this by myself and I'm not
disrespecting that you win even though
they don't got no army
go sell some medicine bitches trying to
get that all uh-huh
the u.s. fired the opening salvo in the
war on Iraq with at least 40 Tomahawk
cruise missiles and precision guided
bombs centering on Baghdad good evening
tonight President George Bush is on
board the aircraft carrier USS Abraham
Lincoln off the California coast it will
be the site of what is essentially his
victory speech in the war against Iraq
what did I say I'm not gloating
but what did I say to that let's say
that we will win it the second straight
day these hardline Iraqis protested the
American presence here mr. president
when do you think they'll hold general
elections in Iraq like the war and real
issue gay people are getting married
folks to women touching on each other's
titty balls wrestling gently stroking
those nipples so they get just sold
and Iraq blowing on
men barbecue like I like you too dull
let's get married man it's crazy what
about your red is gross
mr. president mr. president sir how do
you explain the continual upheaval in
Iraq even after the capture of Saddam
Hussein why are you doing this man
I thought she's my black brother why you
ask me questions like this
fine I'll answer your stupid areas
question here's how I feel about Iraq I
feel like you guys keep trying to
distract people with Iraq when I'm
focusing on other things namely the moon
yes I said it the moon can't be
distracted what's going on with the war
or what's wrong with your coming stop
worrying about that I got that under
control lock focus from space nigga the
United States of space because I
stopping at the moon
write this down am a or as much as back
to the October laws red rocks
[Music]
[Applause]